في خضم مسارها الروتيني ويومياتها
المعتاده يحدث ان تسجل حرب اوكرانيا بين
حين واخر وقائع جديده قد لا تعرف قيمتها
العسكريه من عدمها وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه اعلنت في بيان استهداف مركز
قياده اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي في شبه
جزيره القرم وسبق البيان الاوكراني اعلان
حاكم مدينه سيفا ستوبول في القرم ان
الدفاعات الروسيه احبطت هجوما صاروخيا على
المدينه التي تضم مقر الاسطول وقد كثف
الجيش الاوكراني في الاسابيع الاخيره
هجماته في القرم باستخدام طائرات بدون
طيار وزوارق مسيره وعمليات انزال لضرب
قواعده وسفن روسيه الضغط الاوكراني امتد
جنوبا اذا اعلنت كييف ان قوه خاصه تابعه
لجهاز الامن المركزي اعترضت ثلاثه زوارق
حربيه روسيه ودمرتها وهي تبحر في نهر
الدينيبرو باقليم خرسون في اقليم خرسون
ايضا تعرضت مناطق في وقت سابق لهجوم روسي
واسع قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انه نفذ
بمئات القذائف الصاروخيه وخلف قتلى وجرحى
مدنيين والحق اضرارا كبيره بالمنازل
والمنشات الطبيه والتعليميه
وعن المعارك في اقليم دونيسك شرقيه
اوكرانيا عرضت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقاطع
لما قالت انها ضربه صاروخيه دمرت قوات
اللواء الخامس والثلاثين من مشاه البحريه
الاوكرانيه